Lawless that's the focus of tonight's
angle
[Music]
now what lawlessness goes unchecked
really bad things happen and under Biden
we see this play out Coast to Coast
because criminals know it's a safe bet
that they're just going to commit crimes
and get away with it
so we're seeing an epidemic of retail
thefts Brazen attacks in broad daylight
and then we see zombies doing and
selling drugs right out in the open
and now migrants from all over the world
are storming into America and
overwhelming are already overwhelmed
border patrol again they come because
Biden's DHS is encouraging them to come
and by the way the encouragement doesn't
have to be explicit it's implicit with
every image of the thousands who are
processed in quickly and then quickly
released into the streets
and the Biden migrant magnet just got
stronger today he's granting 470 000
Venezuelan migrants temporary protected
status which allows them to get work
permits now what's that going to lead to
of course a further explosion and the
number of people coming in so tonight in
Eritrea and Morocco Pakistan and Chile
it will be sold over social media as
Biden giving away free work permits all
you need to do is get there
so for what seven thousand dollars U.S
we can help you
get your dreams come true all of it
yeah that's just what we need more
crowding of our schools and more
downward pressure on wages thanks Joe
and you may be asking now why do the
Venezuelans get this temporary protected
status and not others
because it's what New York Liberals are
demanding that's why top of my list has
been temporary protective status for
Venezuelans yes we spoke about it
yesterday the president uh tipped me off
and said we've been heard he understands
and it ensures the problem is only going
to get worse including the drain on City
budgets and as I said School
overcrowding now I promise you today
it's Venezuelans and tomorrow it's going
to be two other countries and so on and
so on we must make sure that we extend
temporary protective status for
Venezuelan El Salvador Honduras
Guatemala Guatemalans Sudan South Sudan
Cameroon and other nations
I think it's Sudanese but
now Biden's Puppet Masters need to keep
those leftists in New York on board
doesn't want to hear them complaining
too much about the border and this is
how they're going to do it
but I have a question tonight when do
Americans get temporary protected status
and how is any of this legal remember
none of this is happening by accident
certainly not happening by mistake this
is the administration's policy the goal
is a slow transformation of America
now to accomplish its goal the DHS has
flown more than 200 000 illegal aliens
directly into 43 cities now I personally
witnessed this in January at the Denver
International Airport it was Unreal
watching this play out
now Democrats defend the situation of
course by just deflecting by saying well
look our immigration system is broken we
have to fix the system
no that's a lie it was essentially fixed
by Donald Trump
and that was one of the many reasons the
left hated him because liberals despise
a tightly controlled border they believe
in globalism and they hate populism or
any type of economic nationalism unless
maybe China is espousing it
they hate America too and they hate
America so much our tradition our
history our culture that they prefer to
start over with millions of poor
migrants who have zero understanding of
our founding or an appreciation of the
American rule of law
unlike during the Great Migration in the
first part of the last century migrant
children today will not be taught an
informed patriotism at school
instead they'll learn to hate the old
America as shameful and racist and we
all know where that's going to lead
so it's playing out at our border and
Beyond is far more important than Hunter
Biden and the money Trail as important
as that is
and it's far more dangerous to our
security than Russia's invasion of
Ukraine more on that next segment
because an open border plus a massive
welfare state plus no risk of
deportation is a recipe not just for
discontent Despair and disunity but an
end to our country as we know it
the Biden team is looking more like a
criminal Enterprise to me every day it's
lawlessness as far as the eye can see
they know their policies are turning
cartels into billion dollar Enterprises
they know they're sending criminals into
our communities
they know they're compromising our
safety and our financial stability
so if this isn't a conspiracy to
undermine U.S sovereignty but I don't
know what is
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else